على وقع مخاوف امنيه موظف البرلمان
الاوروبي امروا بازاله تطبيق تيك توك من
هواتفهم المحموله لكن القرار لم يلقى
قبولا لدى موظفي البرلمان الاوروبي ضاربين
بتهديدات الامن السيبراني المزعومه عرض
الحائط
البرلمان الاوروبي امر موظفي بازاله تيك
توك من الاجهزه المستخدمه في العمل بسبب
مخاوف وتتعلق بحمايه البيانات اعتراض
البرلمانيين الاوروبيين على ازاله تطبيق
تيك توك خرج الى وسائل الاعلام الذين عزوا
موقفا بان التطبيق الصيني يمكنه من الوصول
الى الشباب وتحديدا جينزي الذي يشكل قاعده
جماهيريه كبيره وبالاخص مع قرب اجراء
انتخابات عام 2024
هناك اكثر من 125 مليون اوروبي يستخدم تيك
توك بنشاط كل شهر كما ان للتطبيق شعبيه
لدى المشرعين الاوروبيين انفسهم حتى ان
المشارع الالماني مالتي جالي لديه ما يصل
الى 36 الف متابع التحول في موقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي من التطبيق الصيني جاء بعد بضعه
اشهر فقط بعدما كان 14 مسؤولا قد وافقوا
رسميا على اطلاق حساب موثق عبر تيك توك